hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday January 16th
2023 what's going on
how are you all right I'm not gonna lie
to you I threw up my [ __ ] back
getting a frozen waffle out of the
freezer
I am laying on my side right now because
of that's the only way I can [ __ ]
talk right now I feel like somebody's
stabbing me in my kidney
you know and you know what the sad thing
is is I've been working out and I've
been stretching
you know I've been [ __ ]
trying to remain flexible at my Advanced
age
oh you [ __ ] [ __ ]
all right
I think if I lay here this is going to
be good all right this this I don't know
how long this podcast is going to be
um
how are you
oh
God damn it
all right here we go okay oh that's it
all right I'm laying on this stupid ass
[ __ ] heating pad is there anything
that does less when you throw at your
back than a [ __ ] heating pad
it's like my nerves are inflamed let's
put some heat on it
all right
okay
all right happy Martin Luther King day
everybody
Martin Luther King Day
the day African Americans acknowledge
one of the great leaders they've ever
had
and white people pretend they care and
take a day off
and go boogie board and out [ __ ]
Santa Monica in his memory dude this is
Martin Luther King would want us to be
out here boogie board
um
holy [ __ ]
oh this feels all right okay we've
adjusted
but I'll tell you right now no matter
how bad my back feels right now
there's no way my back feels worse than
the Way San Diego Charger fans feel
um
in defense of the San Diego Chargers
organization they've been asking for a
new football stadium for years
right
down there in Qualcomm 3com whatever the
[ __ ] it was called
and San Diego is like hey man isn't the
weather enough for you
we're not going to be held hostage
by you [ __ ] [ __ ] you haven't even
wanted you've never won a Super Bowl
and then San Diego is like well that's
because this Stadium must be buried on
top of a Native American burial ground
or something something happened in San
Diego's like we don't give a [ __ ]
all right Finders Keepers losers weepers
all right
send that [ __ ] to the open network we
don't give a [ __ ] and then San Diego
Chargers was like all right
well we're just gonna [ __ ] pack our
[ __ ] up and leave in the city of San
Diego's like you don't have the [ __ ]
balls and the charger is like oh yeah
you don't think so you don't think so
packing up the bag yeah you'll be back
they already got a team up there called
the Rams
and they even left they went to St Louis
for like [ __ ] I don't know 25 [ __ ]
years
they're like oh You're Gonna Miss This
one with God and they're like yeah
you're not going anywhere and then they
[ __ ] left
and they went up to La Memorial Coliseum
cited the first two [ __ ] Super Bowls
and now they got a new stadium so far
but you know what
the ghosts
of what this Stadium sat on followed
them and they were up 27 to nothing
in Jacksonville Florida against Trevor
Lawrence who you cannot convince me is
not a robot
the most beautiful lifeless eyes in
football
Trevor Lawrence nothing affects that guy
um
and I don't know who was controlling him
in the first half but
it was like they bet the charges
you know you try to look off his safety
he was like looking right at a
cornerback and would throw it right to
him in the first half
it was a tale of two robots to everybody
[ __ ] game was 27 and nothing at the
half
you know freckles is like my wife's like
why don't we go out tonight I'm like
yeah [ __ ] it let's go out I mean what
this game stinks right so we went out I
had myself a nice little Italian meal
out here
some [ __ ] protein Oh Billy protein
face
like I said I've been back at the gym
can't you guys hear how healthy I am
I've been doing squats
I've been doing some Coral lift
oh
I've been [ __ ]
kicking ass finally losing my goddamn
covered weight you know
Oh Billy fat tits
was getting them [ __ ] you know I was
getting my chesticles back in shape
again
I was having the third Peck my belly
goat there's nothing worse though when
your belly sticks out
the second it's sticking out as far as
your pecs you just look like a man
titted [ __ ]
that's just it just is what it is
um
so I've been killing it at the gym and
then of course now I gotta throw out my
back so anyway my wife wants to go out
to dinner I love my wife let's take her
out we go out we have a good time we
ended up stomping off
add a little uh a little after hours
place and I going on look all of a
sudden it's 30 to 20.
and I was like wait a minute
are the charges gonna do what the [ __ ]
they always do in the goddamn playoffs
are they gonna [ __ ] lose again
to a team that they have beat and lo and
behold
it's the second half
right
the Jacksonville Jaguars halftime
adjustments is that they they did a hard
drive switch on Trevor Lords
then all of a sudden the man couldn't
miss
you know still had that lifeless look in
his eyes
you can't convince me he's not a robot
and doesn't ride on shirtless on a white
robot horse like I feel like that's how
he comes to the games but the NFL just
maybe that's what it is
after the former players did that that
class action suit for CTE I think that
they've already begun switching over to
robots and I think Trevor Lawrence is
the first one I mean tell me he has it
tell me that guy tell me that that's a
person
um
so then the charges actually have a
chance to kind of ice it with the
[ __ ] field goal
and the kicker comes out Charles Dickens
the fourth whatever his [ __ ] name is
and he misses it
right
[ __ ] Jacksonville scores goes for a
two-point conversion as I'm screaming
don't do this
why would you do this
oh because some athletes said this is
the right thing to do and lo and behold
it worked the math team was right now
it's 30 to 28.
and then I don't know Chicago goes three
and out Chicago San Diego goes three and
out and then [ __ ]
they let the robot come back on the
field
and he emotionlessly drives them down
the [ __ ] field
right a gutsy fourth down [ __ ] call
whatever the [ __ ] they did
running the ball
around the outside all the way down to
like the 18th and then that field goal
kicker comes in
kicks the field goal and Olive Jackson
Phil celebrates now I want to first of
all I want to give a shout out to the
Jacksonville Jaguars and the City of
Jacksonville one of the best cups of
coffee I ever got in my life
was in Jacksonville
first time I ever tried alligator and
the only time I ever tried alligator was
in Jacksonville
it does not taste like chicken
okay anybody goes when any whenever
anybody's trying to get you to taste
something new they tell you it tastes
like chicken and that the truth is
the only it's only one thing in the
world that tastes like chicken and
that's chicken
and it's [ __ ]
delicious like chicken it's not even
close chicken it's the best tasting
[ __ ] animal
on the planet
to the point even if you can't cook if
you make some chicken it's still gonna
taste all right
right everybody you don't undercook it
I mean you could [ __ ] up like if
somebody doesn't know how to cook and
they're going to try to cook for you
they're making chicken let's be honest
they're not firing up a grill I'm gonna
try to [ __ ] make a steak
you know or sear it on both sides on the
skillet on top of the stove
finish it in the oven and bring it back
out for a garlic butter bath they ain't
doing that [ __ ]
they're taking a [ __ ] chicken cutlet
S one side's the other side they throw a
little salt and pepper on it you could
deal with it you could [ __ ] deal with
it
um
first place and only place I ever shot a
gun with a silencer Jacksonville Florida
I had a great I've had great times out
there so shout out to them
condolences to LaDainian Tomlinson who
went to that TCU Georgia game
TC TCU uh grad
watched his team lose by 58 [ __ ]
points
I'm still not even sure TCU still even
has a football program after that
[ __ ] loss
Jesus Christ
right and then the dating right as he's
shaking off that loss getting excited
and watching his former team the charges
up 27 nothing
he watches him [ __ ] blow it again
[ __ ] blow it
I'm telling you when January comes
around there's one thing that you can
Bank on other than the fact that you're
going to promise yourself that you're
going to go to the gym and get your
six-pack back knowing full well you're
gonna [ __ ] throw out your back and be
laying on a purple mat that's heated a
couple weeks later right that's a
guaranteed the beginning of every year
that gyms are going to be overly crowded
until about January 20th
and then people are going to start
dropping like flies
and the other thing that you can bet on
is that the Chargers the Vikings and the
bills are going to lose in the playoffs
two out of three of those things
happened
almost three out of three
with the Buffalo Bills in their
lackluster [ __ ] performance
is they're somehow basking in this
National
[ __ ] where they think that everybody's
rooting for them
some woman in the crowd actually had a
sign that said Buffalo Bills America's
team it's like a let's take it down a
little bit
your wings aren't that good all right
I'm rooting for you I hope it happens if
it doesn't I don't give a [ __ ]
I know that they're not nice people out
in Buffalo
they're just making you seem like you're
nice because everyone feels bad for you
but I have first-hand experience with
Buffalo Bills fans when I wear that
Patriots hat to a bills Jets game
rooting for the bills
and that dude pushed me in the back when
I was in the [ __ ] bathroom
as I was taking a piss the [ __ ]
coward that he was pushing an old man
like me in the back
huh
um
I'm still rooting for him because only
because they're my Super Bowl
my Super Bowl pick all right so I just
want to be right that's the only reason
why I'm rooting for them I'm not rooting
for them
you know for any other [ __ ] reason
all right the bills Mafia and oh we
crushed tables and all that [ __ ]
um
anyway so my money is actually on them I
bet them at the beginning of the year to
win the Super Bowl and then I I watch
whatever the [ __ ] that was
against some quarterback named Skyler
what's his face from [ __ ] Utah
Community College by the way how many
more backup quarterbacks are just going
to come Waltzing in
to take over for starting quarterbacks
from major colleges and just absolutely
crush it have they changed the rules so
much on the offense
or is this just like the era of the
quarterback I'm trying to remember the
last time a backup quarterback came in
and didn't just go out and just [ __ ]
act like the starting quarterback
I mean who are these people you got that
[ __ ] kid Purdy
oh [ __ ] my back um
let's see if this works
you got that kid Purdy
for the San Francisco 49ers right
kid won his first five starts nobody's
ever done that all of these Hall of Fame
quarterbacks all of these [ __ ] guys
when back in the day you could [ __ ]
hit a quarterback none of them ever did
it in some [ __ ] guy now I've never
heard of I've never heard of that I
don't know where he played [ __ ]
college football I'm not saying I'm the
be-all end-all of no one about college
football and [ __ ] but I never heard of
this guy this guy [ __ ] comes in he's
lights out
[ __ ] lights out some guy named Skyler
comes in lights out
Baker Mayfield gets [ __ ] traded to
the goddamn Rams whoever the [ __ ]
playing
quarterback now for the Panthers lights
out they're covering every [ __ ] week
I'm losing money I'm throwing out my
back
Colt McCoy I didn't know he was still in
the [ __ ]
goddamn League lights out just the best
backup in the [ __ ] you know
the backup quarterback is supposed to
suck that's why he's the backup he comes
in and there's a noticeable drop off
from the starter you don't keep [ __ ]
winning
you don't come out against the Buffalo
Bills and all their goddamn weapons with
some kid named Skyler who sounds like he
should have a [ __ ] protractor in his
goddamn hand and Tyreek Hill
is hurt
and they hang with them the whole
goddamn game
I'm still rooting for the bills my
money's still on them but I will tell
you this is the kids say I was whelmed
by that performance no I was underwelt
what am I talking about I was
underwhelmed
they should have came in there and
kicked the [ __ ] out of them they didn't
even cover the [ __ ] spread
there was no [ __ ] on the ground the only
[ __ ] on the ground was from the Buffalo
Bills going oh my God are we gonna
[ __ ] lose to these guys
what's their quarterback's last name
again I don't [ __ ] know
who gives a [ __ ] why don't you go out
there and try and stop him
oh
anyway
oh my back's coming back here we go it's
it's coming back I want the world to
know
oh [ __ ]
really is amazing that they just haven't
figured out the back yet they just have
no [ __ ] answers
the only answer you have is never get
the operation
never get a [ __ ] operation
you're much better to just [ __ ] roll
around on the floor like this I think
that's my own personal opinion
so the Jacksonville Jaguars they Advance
the [ __ ] New York football Giants
they don't lose in January you don't
need to tell a [ __ ] Pats fan that
right they went right through goddamn
February catching [ __ ] footballs off
their helmet they're [ __ ] tainting
their goddamn shoelaces right
that is their legacy it's amazing new
players come in it doesn't make a
difference this that it's it's in the
DNA
of the New York football Giants the
Vikings it is in their DNA
that they're gonna [ __ ] lose and
that's exactly what that's exactly what
they did God damn it
um
so anyway I don't know who the Bills
play next week
um
my money if I had to do my bed over
again I think it might be the 49ers
versus the Kansas City Chiefs I think
the Kansas City Chiefs are going to go
to the Super Bowl and probably
I don't know if they're going to win it
all depends I will tell you this I am
really sick and tired of Patrick Mahomes
and those stupid forward laterals that
aren't forward laterals anymore every
time you're gonna you're gonna [ __ ]
go to sakum it looks like he frisbied a
[ __ ] purse two yards and then I gotta
listen to the United States oh my God
who can't he's underhanding the ball
that's how I play ketchup my two and a
half year old son
what are we flipping out I don't like
that I don't like the way he runs
there's something about the way he runs
and then he just just uh he just [ __ ]
throw that underhand [ __ ] ball it's
like take a sack like a man and throw it
away stop with this [ __ ]
I don't know what it is it's just that's
what he looks like he's like
I don't know why I've never seen a man
underhand a purse but that's what it
looks like to me it's a [ __ ] forward
lateral and it's not a forward lateral
anymore you know maybe that's why all
these no-name backup quarterbacks
there's so many options
can light over to backwards sidewards
sideways forward doesn't matter no one
can touch you
did you see that roughing the passer
called that the Giants got at the end of
that [ __ ] Vikings game I mean how
would it take what was he supposed to do
you know pretty soon you're gonna have
to like it's gonna be like wedding night
you got to carry the quarterback Across
the Threshold and lay him down like he's
a virgin
kiss the top of his helmet
[Music]
um
there's a flag on the play we got a
personal foul on the defense
not putting enough emotion when you kiss
the quarterback's helmet
um anyway
oh [ __ ] working it out hey I'm
working it out
hey working out the Pack's getting
worked out here um
yeah complete horseshit call
and then there was also uh one of those
games that was just decided I think it
was the Buffalo uh I mean the 49ers game
they just completely ignored
oh I know they dumped it off and then
there was a wide receiver down the field
who just grabbed the safety on both
sides of his [ __ ] shoulder pads and
held on to him
yeah gets the Seahawks and the guy runs
in for a touchdown they showed it up
close they were they were commending
this guy for his downfield blocking up
close in slow motion just two handfuls
of Jersey they didn't say anything and
then they showed the Seattle guy [ __ ]
kicking the turf make then making it
look like he was frustrated with how
good the 49ers were he was frustrated
that there was no call is what I was
I wasn't matching that was my take
ah
my bad back here now you know what's the
worst at my age if you just lay on your
back long enough your nose starts
getting clogged up like you have a cold
like I am a [ __ ] mess right now
um I have slippers on and plaid pajama
bottoms
with the hoodie and a thermal okay you
getting that picture right there this is
this is like this is the outfit you wear
when you die at home
of what they initially think
foreign
how many times how many [ __ ] times
have you been driving by a [ __ ]
complex and you see them Wheeling
somebody out one of those hospital
gerties with the oxygen thing and they
got the Plaid pajama bottoms oh my God
I'm I'm wearing my death outfit
he was laughing and joking the night
before and I don't know I just woke up
and he was a strange color so I called
the ambulance
um
wow
anyway you know it's funny if I actually
had silk pajamas you know that the EMTs
are like all right this is definitely a
little nose candy here right before bed
he's doing some stripes
riding the rail
um
by the way I've been continuing to watch
Amazing movies
um
trying to get some inspiration here in a
different direction because I'm writing
something right now
and um
I watched Jackie Brown
which I'd only seen once I saw it in the
movie theater and when I went to go see
Jackie Brown
in 97 or 98 when it came out I was like
most most mouth-breathing morons I went
in there and I wanted to see Pulp
Fiction part two
all right but Tarantino's like I already
[ __ ] did that I'm gonna do something
different and then I went in there like
this isn't what I already saw and had
the nerve
to be upset
and over the years people are telling me
like I think that's his best [ __ ]
movie I love Jackie Brown so I was like
I gotta go back and see this thing okay
I was a [ __ ] idiot in the late 90s
not like I'm not an idiot right now
and I went back and watched it and now
it it might be my favorite Samuel
Jackson performance
he was unfucking believable in that
movie
uh I would sit down and watch it again
tonight that's how much I enjoyed it and
uh
Pam Greer was amazing all of that [ __ ]
she was doing when the feds first
started talking to her
in the parking garage
and
the question she was acting and the look
on her face as she knew like what to say
what not to say
and how she has got she's got to play
that whole thing acting like she's
helping out Sam Jackson acting like
she's helping out the [ __ ] cops but
she's just helping herself out it was
[ __ ] amazing Robert De Niro playing
that [ __ ]
lose a character uh
what's her face there um
Bridget Fonda
and I realized she was actually laying
on the couch watching her one of her dad
Peter Fonda's movies
that dirty married crazy Harry that
movie I was telling you about earlier
that has one of my favorite lines ever
in it
in the beginning Peter Fonda's character
hooks up with some chick that like bank
robbers and they're going into town like
case in the town to see if there's a
place they can rip off and Peter Fonda
goes uh I like this town this is a good
town and then his buddy goes and it
sounds a good town
when you're banging a broad
[Music]
stuff like that when you bang a front
um you sound just like the guy in the
Warner Brothers movie Shut up shutting
up
the Warner Brother cartoons I should say
um anyway I give that five out of five
freckled thumbs up
uh Jackie Brown [ __ ] incredible movie
um
and before that I watched Casino another
movie I was wrong about
I just felt it was too like the vice The
Head and the vice and the [ __ ]
Nikki getting beaten to death and buried
alive with his brother that was just too
much for me uh
you know seeing the eye pop out and [ __ ]
it was too much but I didn't realize you
know I went back and watched it I I
would that's another one I would watch
again
and uh I want I want a movie suggestion
from you guys because those are two like
you know huge directors everybody knows
their work
give me something underground give me
something
what movie was that come on
Pacino and he
I should watch that I haven't seen that
since that one came out
everybody tells me that movie's [ __ ]
incredible I gotta go back and watch
that I had like massive massive massive
massive [ __ ] add in the 90s
do you know I Saw The Usual Suspects and
somewhere in that movie I daydreamed
and just sort of checked out for a good
20 minutes and in the end of the movie
when this no I'm not going to spoil it
here whatever the big reveal was
the butler did it or you know the end of
the mystery like is the whole crowd of
the movie theater was like oh
what happened
I wasn't listening I just kind of zoned
out
I zoned out after the police lineup
um
yeah when Benicio del Toro is like ah
get all you [ __ ] when he did
that I thought that was hilarious
and uh
I don't know I think I just started
thinking about my own life and will I
ever get to do a movie can you imagine
being a movie look how good these guys
how do you get as good at acting as
these guys guys I just started thinking
about that [ __ ] I started thinking about
what if I you know I went what if I had
gone to a different high school and I I
majored in drama or I just started
thinking all of this [ __ ] then all of a
sudden it was just the end of the movie
that used to happen to me all the
[ __ ] time I would go to see movies
and um
yeah there's halfway through I would
just start thinking of [ __ ] and I
couldn't even focus on them so I should
probably go back watch The Usual
Suspects
and heat maybe I'll watch that this week
that'll be good you know what's funny is
my wife absolutely loves movies and uh
but she also likes watching shows about
you know those murder shows
she also likes watching uh those murder
shows right so
um
you know I don't like watching that
before I go to bed I like watching fake
murders so the last couple of nights
like
the movies I've been watching are so
good that she actually stops watching
the murder shows and she ends up
watching you know what I'm watching
on my laptop
uh which made me feel good because my
wife's definitely the more artsy of the
two of us like she actually like goes to
museums
and can appreciate what you know what's
on the wall I can't appreciate it unless
it's something I recognize
you know what I mean like when I go to a
[ __ ] Museum and it's
a bunch of just you know paint on a
canvas that isn't of it was that called
abstract
um
you know
I'm not smart enough I guess
to know what that is you know
she is she can figure all of that out
and she can actually watch Casino too
she's she's the whole gamut I'm just
sort of straightforward right basically
if there's not a car chase and some
titties to me I feel like Hollywood
didn't really give me a movie
all right
I don't know what I'm talking about
right now I'm just trying to [ __ ] fix
my goddamn back here all right let's do
some reads here for the week
all right here we go
we got some reads here for the week this
is still recording okay good it is it is
it is still recording all right oh look
who it is everyone
can you believe it it's all zip
grow it up
talk about your goals for the new year
well I'd like to not have a [ __ ] bad
back I'd like to be able
to take a frozen waffle out of the
goddamn freezer
and not end up spending the rest of my
morning laying on the floor of my
[ __ ] back
oh
is that a goal is that is that good
enough for you
you [ __ ] job hiring [ __ ]
um it's hard to find people who are so
good at what they do
so good is underlined oh my God
that's like when Foodies talk about a
restaurant that's how they want to read
oh my God have you been to Penelope's
oh my God it's so good they always say
that I hate that so good that dropped
their voice down I always wanted like
[ __ ] karate chop him right in the
throat right as they say it
you know like a spy movie you do it
really quick in public and nobody sees
it and then they collapse and as
everybody rushes over to help them you
walk out slowly wearing a Hawaiian shirt
see you blend in with the Taurus
um
anyway
it's hard to find people who are so good
at what they do it's like if you're
hiring
it's like if you're hiring how can you
find the best people for all the
different roles on your team easy zip
um and right now you can try it for free
at ziprecruiter.com
unfortunately you also have new hiring
challenges for 2023 it's going to be
harder to hire [ __ ] people
like finding qualified candidates
or adjusting to candidates work
preferences I know all these [ __ ]
want to work from home
[ __ ] take a gummy right
uh thankfully there's a place you can go
there's a place you can go where you can
[ __ ] hire people ah all right I can't
get up yet
what
the thing
I can't get my [ __ ] feet up on that
now she has this pillow that's like
shaped like a [ __ ] wedge of cheese
if you elevate your land force your
lower back oh thank you Dr Hilt oh
well yeah as long as I don't move
everything's fine
you got to be [ __ ] kidding me we're
still going to the movies today right
no I'm going
I'm going
I said I'm going and that's it
um unfortunately I think when the
podcast's over I'll just [ __ ]
I'll bust out the yoga mat and I'll work
this out here uh unfortunately you have
new hiring challenges for 2023.
um
yeah you know what you got to go around
the fact that everyone's been treating
their employees like [ __ ] for so goddamn
long that most people don't like
you know once the pandemic came around
they're like hey wait a minute yeah time
to think like why am I allowing myself
to be treated like that all right
thankfully there's a place you can go
that can help you conquer these
challenges and achieve your hiring goals
it's zip up uh right now you can try it
for free at ziprecruiter.com why
zip
zipper Courier uses its powerful
matching technology to find the right
candidate for your job see a candidate
who'd be perfect for your job no problem
zip recruiter makes it easy to send them
a personal invite you slide into their
professional DMS so they're more likely
to apply
Hey Big Boy
you want to drive a truck for me a zip
recruiter also offers attention grabbing
labels that speak to job flexibility
like remote training provided
and more oh that's what they like
remote Trading
provided you can train for this job at
your house see for yourself go to go to
this exclusive web address to try
ZipRecruiter for free ziprecruiter.com
again that zip
grow it up .com
zip recruiter the smartest way to hire I
can't [ __ ] breathe
can't lay on my back this long and all
of a sudden it's like I have a cold and
this is it Nia do you know I'm I was
saying joking earlier I'm wearing the
clothes this is the exact outfit when
you get wheeled out on a Gertie into an
ambulance when you [ __ ] die suddenly
or you have some sort of cardiac episode
yeah you're you're in your pajamas yeah
my pajamas with like a hoodie on
um just laying on my back is making it
nice did the heat kick in on this uh it
didn't he has not kicked in on this
thing thankfully I I mean I hate a
heating pad I know but it's it's it's
it's gonna help your back my nerve is
inflamed why do I want to put heat on it
I don't know don't you want to put ice
on it how about an ice pack for the
[ __ ] reptilian man that you met you
married
all right you know what all I'm going to
do is just have a bunch of non-doctors
that listen to this podcast
arguing back and forth about what's
better heat or ice all right butcher box
100 butcher box wait why is it the copy
it's a new year and the perfect time
make sure you're doing the best you can
for you and your family
oh it's a new year it's a perfect time
to make sure you're doing the best for
you and your family
um with butcher box everybody 100
grass-fed beef free range organic
chicken pork raised crepe free and wild
caught Seafood you don't know what it's
gonna do Nene
uh she mainly raised no antibiotics or
added hormones get just what you want
delivered right to your doorstep free
shipping for the Continental us and no
surprise fees choose from a variety of
box plan options from curated to
customized
and change your plan whenever you want
enjoy a range of high quality cuts that
are hard to come by at the grocery store
at an amazing value hey can you turn the
light on by the way I can't even see
this recipe inspiration guides tips and
hacks yes please
some are even
personalized
well that just made it worse okay now I
got it all right uh so you can cook up
mouth-watering Meals all right we got
the momentum back I love having my what
the [ __ ]
why did it just move like I love having
my food
come from a quality Source a freezer
freezer full of food makes it easy to
plan healthy meals it's also a great way
to plan for a pandemic you know you get
that Jeffrey Dahmer freezer you put it
in the [ __ ] uh garage you load it up
uh get the New Year bundle for free plus
ten dollars off when you sign up today
that's a 14 ounce pork tenderloin two
pounds of ground turkey and four top
sirloin steaks for free in your first
box my mouth is watering Here sign up at
butcherbox.com and use the code Burr to
claim this offer
all right there we go where are we in
the podcast here 35 minutes in it's time
for the questions
oh [ __ ]
all right Celsius versus Fahrenheit why
did I start this [ __ ] debate
Bill last week you read an email
defending Celsius
I didn't defend Celsius it wasn't being
charged with anything I just said it and
seemed to make more sense considering
water freezes at zero and boils at a
hundred it seemed like easier numbers to
remember for a dummy like me
I wasn't defending Celsius all right
Celsius never went to Epstein Island
allegedly
um anyway you were defending Celsius
from a bloke who opened his email saying
he grew up with Celsius but you closed
the email saying yeah well you're used
to it that's why you like Fahrenheit
better
well that sounds like me did I already
forget what he said two paragraphs
earlier all right I apologize for that a
lot of open-minded non-us bred persons
would agree with him and me
can I just tell you guys how much I love
that sentence a lot of open-minded
non-us bred persons would agree with him
and me who are they you just invented
these people
and then you complimented saying that
they were open-minded
you know there's a lot of people out
there that would agree with him and me
hey you know what there's a lot of
people that would agree with me
I can't give you any examples but I
could make the same giant [ __ ]
statement all right here's a good
stand-up routine explaining fahrenheit's
superiority
um
all right am I supposed to watch this
right now I'll listen I don't want to
see a [ __ ] stand-up routine about
Fahrenheit
um
I mean that's that's above my pay grade
all right you know what if you like
Fahrenheit go ahead I mean
they're still using it so
all right porch talk and second home
hey Bill
maybe you do have one but just don't
talk about it but I was wondering if you
ever considered a second home you could
Retreat to for three months out of the
year
um
for three months
come back to my house out here and
there's raccoons living in it what the
[ __ ] who goes away for three months
um yeah I have I have I have a vacation
home I just rent them and then I leave
and then I'm not responsible for the
gutters and the water problems and all
of that [ __ ]
um if you don't where would you go tell
the realtor you need a front porch with
the view
oh that's a fun thing
honestly uh if it wasn't so far away if
if I didn't give a [ __ ] about getting on
a plane
um
in rural France
so I would be forced to speak French
I would spend three months out there
maybe go to the Tour de France down in
the Pyrenees
you know
I would do that
I would live in Italy
any of those Mediterranean places even
more places I'd never been to like Spain
and Greece they just don't seem amazing
but if we were talking continental
United States
which is most likely uh Massachusetts
absolutely
you know go back to there all the places
that I love to eat that would be amazing
um
I know it's a big time Hollywood thing
for some reason to go to Wyoming and
Montana
um I've seen enough of Yellowstone to
know that I'm not going to fit in out
there and I don't need the Kevin Costner
character [ __ ] yelling at me
um so I wouldn't go to that
I'd let those people have their country
out there you know
um
where would I go
I don't know I've always liked Milwaukee
I like Minneapolis like uh Chattanooga
Tennessee I like Jacksonville
um
I don't know Eric I would be definitely
someplace back East I think it would
just be in Massachusetts
um I would have a place
and um
it just doesn't seem relaxing to me to
get on a plane though and have to fly
five and a half hours to get all the way
the [ __ ] out there
um so I would probably
do what a lot of people do out here
which is get a um
a place out in like Palm Desert
so then you can just get in the car
drive out there
but at that point I mean I just feel
like just [ __ ] rent the goddamn thing
then you don't have to deal with it you
know
you know what I'd love to do when I like
rent a house is leave it [ __ ]
immaculate
you know like
clean it all up and throw the garbage
out and all that
underrated
renting something and treating it with
respect
I always hated that thing hey it's a
rental like having a rental car and you
like beat the [ __ ] out of it
um
I don't know just think that when you're
younger I understand it when you get
older I think it's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
thing to do all right Real World
Illuminati oh no
hey Billy grounded brains
uh with all you do you're probably not
following World Domination news as much
yeah I kind of got out of that because
it freaks me out and there's like no
solution and most people don't care
and then you walk around
freaking out about [ __ ] and you don't
even 100 really know that it's true
um I just know that there's a lot of
[ __ ] psychos out there and they're
planning to do horribly horrible [ __ ]
things
and that I blame God for it because God
makes the psychos it's not the devil all
right the devil is God's excuse
all right he tries harder on some people
than he does on others that's all he
tightens the screws down on some people
you get a nice level-headed empathetic
person that does not seek power and the
rest of them you know that whole thing
they got to screw loose yeah God didn't
tighten it down it has nothing to do
with the Devil
all right
the devil is like you know when you know
feminists are always just blaming men
for all of their [ __ ] problems
me I really wish I could sit up right
now and just look at the look on your
face when I said that
um you don't feel that feminist that a
little bit
oh yeah no we know that I'm an [ __ ]
but don't you think that you know not
all of women's problems
are because of men
most of them don't I I would I would
think though
your guy's inability to get along with
one another
yeah no you're not gonna do that what
I try to you know Gaslight the situation
and make us turn on each other it's not
gonna happen Nia Your Entertainment is
watching women yell at each other and
not get along with each other and
[ __ ] animal conflict resolution
okay
all right I'll leave that alone
um
it's your sports all right fair enough
um I would like to bring your attention
to the Davos meeting going on this week
it's a collection of the richest people
in the world who get together to
supposedly figure out how to steer
population in a better Direction they
are led by a guy named Klaus Schwab
who is the head of the world economic
forum
he talks like a bond villain with a fat
tongue German accent they pretend to
care about Humanity but it's all a money
grab of course yes absolutely and CNN
and Fox News will not cover it on any
[ __ ] level
um but if an actor says something or a
stand-up comedian says something that
either CNN or Fox doesn't like they'll
[ __ ] jump all over it like the
comedian is Klaus Schwab
um the way they tackle climate change is
to push policies to keep normal people
living in a lower quality of life in the
name of the planet while all I love when
politicians do that you go you know we
gotta tighten the belt it's like dude my
[ __ ] checkbook is balanced
you're the [ __ ] that overspent the
[ __ ] taxes why don't you tighten your
belt uh anyway while owning all of the
companies that pollute and create waste
uh keep in mind none of these people are
elected but they control a lot of
aspects of Our Lives they're meeting in
Davos Switzerland
hilarious Switzerland's the smartest
[ __ ] people out there acting like
they're neutral
yeah man we you know we don't want to
get involved and then they have meetings
like this there uh they all fly in on
private jets and the Swiss Army has 5
000 active troops protecting them how do
you know this how do you know how they
fly in private do you have an app where
you can watch the Illuminati uh just for
the record they warned about virus a few
years back and pushed governments to
invest in their pandemic protocols
well maybe they know something then in
like a a good way
uh the ones who didn't got some I told
you so's
uh another warning of a major cyber
security breakdown one might guess it
would be financial and since they all
they own all the land and resources they
won't have to worry about all Financial
records being destroyed since it's all
ones and zeros at this point hold on to
your butt Billy it's gonna be a wild
decade or maybe not
all right the fact that you wrote or
maybe not is like
you know
shows that you're a little bit rational
that you don't [ __ ] believe 100 of
this [ __ ]
um
yeah all right well that's a bunch of
scary [ __ ] that I can do nothing about
um
all right new artificial intelligent
programs oh Jesus out of The Frying Pan
Into the Fire
does this sit here I think this is the
last one I'm gonna do before my [ __ ]
I [ __ ] try to work this bad problem
out um
okay AI
hey hi Bill I'm a big fan of your comedy
and your podcast well thank you I always
make sure I listen while I am commuting
to and from work I just wanted to get
your opinion on all the new AI apps and
websites that seem to be coming out now
uh
um
there are AI apps for artwork where a
computer will pretty much make artwork
based on whatever you can tell it to
make for instance you can make you could
say make Hitler
wear a dunce cap and it will draw a
picture of it
okay
there's another program called chat GPT
this is getting attention because
students are using it to write papers
for school no brother and what it comes
up with will not be identified on the
plagiarizing programs that teachers use
you can also use it to write songs or
stories
I was recently playing with it and I
said write a Bill Burr joke oh God did
it starts smoking
um this is the joke it came up with oh
God
I don't know what's worse people who are
always late or people who are always
early lay people are like hey I'm sorry
I'm late but early people are like hey
I'm sorry I'm early but I just couldn't
wait to bother you
Jesus Christ they think I'm that bad a
comedian
late people who are always
lay people are like hey I'm sorry I'm
late that's it that's all the [ __ ]
juice you squeezed out of that
let me see if I can Bill Burr this up
with some [ __ ] and some
bad voices
I'll do my impression my impression of
people's impression of me I don't know
what's worse
people are always [ __ ] late
the people are always [ __ ] early
people are like uh sorry I'm late but
early people are like hey sorry I'm
early but I just couldn't wait to bother
you I wouldn't [ __ ] do this [ __ ] that
robot uh but it'll get better
it'll get better just like all of these
gas combustion people who are
complaining about how long it takes to
charge a car an electric car which is
hilarious what you really do is get out
and plug it in as you go into your house
and you wake up the next day with a full
[ __ ] tank every goddamn day
all these gas combustion people like
well what about when I just if I decide
I want to drive to Kentucky
when do you do that never
um those those
electric ports they're just going to
charge faster and faster and faster
that's it because they know that that's
what's stopping you
I don't want a fast vehicle with more
space to put [ __ ]
um after I saw that I was curious to see
what your thoughts were
um yeah you know what I don't give a
[ __ ] how about that I used to give a
[ __ ] and you know what giving a [ __ ] was
just [ __ ] pointless it was lonely
I actually had an economics major yell
at me
trying to claim that the Federal Reserve
was part of the government and she said
I majored in economics
and I kept saying you're wrong
and then the other guy was going uh San
Diego a whale's vagina and they were
just sitting there acting like I was a
[ __ ] lunatic and I wasn't I was 100
right
but they were in the goddamn Matrix so
that's what I find
when you're into conspiracy theory
you're either going to be frustrated
talking with somebody who
doesn't believe in it or Worse you're
going to meet somebody that is into it
and they're going to just you guys are
just going to sit there freaking each
other out
knowing there's nothing you can do about
it
you know you're both talking to each
other going I was hoping you were the
Tom Cruise or Will Smith
that was going to go to Switzerland and
stop this meeting from happening
oh it's not you well it's not me either
all right you want to go get some
[ __ ] wings like what do you do with
it after that oh my [ __ ] back all
right I gotta work this this thing out
here
this is the worst I throw my back out in
a while
you know
that's gonna be the great thing about
[ __ ] robots
they won't be they won't throw their
backs out
you know what that's why they've never
figured the back out
because they're like well who gives a
[ __ ] that we can't figure out out the
spine
you know we got Robots coming
let's see if standing up
let's see how standing up Works standing
up standing up oh you [ __ ] oh
oh that is not good
that's not good at all oh come on man
I wanted to go to the movies
all right well I'm not laying on that
[ __ ] heating pad all it does is just
make me feel like I have a fever
I think walking around rather than just
laying down is going to be a better
thing all right are people really
listening to me just
complaining about my back all right
people I'm sorry
I'm about eight minutes short
you know I'm going San Diego charges on
this I had a good first half
my condolences to San Diego Charger
fence I don't know why stuff like this
keeps happening
um but you know you have to pay for that
you guys have perfect weather down there
and you have beautiful women who aren't
show business so just know that you do
have that
all right and you guys can go out in
your lovely weather and hold each other
and be tan and go surfing or whatever it
is you do down in that Utopia
um I love how I'm talking about it like
there's still the San Diego Chargers
they're not they're the Los Angeles
Chargers
right
I don't know they'll always be the San
Diego Chargers it'll always be the
Oakland Raiders and always be the
Baltimore Colts to me okay this walking
around is getting a little better here
all right that's the podcast everybody
um
go [ __ ] yourselves and I will check in
on you
on Thursday